the movie opens up with a harrowing
scene of a school attack with children
screaming and paramedics rushing to the
area among the helpers is a psychiatrist
named Dr Stern who enters the school and
funds A young Wendy traumatized by The
Experience Dr Stern Comforts the little
girl and promises that everything will
be okay the scene then fast forwards by
several years where an adult Wendy wakes
up from her sleep it is revealed that
she's struggling with mental health
issues and is taking medication to cope
Wendy lives with her husband Lars and
their son Carl in a small house although
they have a very close Bond every single
day is a challenge for them due to their
limited finances later we get to know
that Wendy works at a diner with a
colleague named elmar normally she is a
shy person by nature and always tries to
avoid people but today she decides to
ask her grumpy boss Angela about her
promotion unfortunately the latter
declines it without remorse despite the
fact that Wendy is her best employee
shortly after while taking out the trash
Wendy meets a homeless man named Merrick
who asks her for the leftover food as
she obliges he suddenly mentions you are
the one and runs away without giving her
any context what a troll on her way back
home Wendy is lost in her thoughts when
suddenly Merrick startles her from
behind he urges her to stop taking her
medication claiming that they suppress
her actual self as expected Wendy thinks
he is crazy so to prove that he has
superpowers Merrick jumps off the
highway bridge and purposefully gets run
over by a vehicle that proved nothing
Wendy is left in utter disbelief at what
she just saw so immediately she calls
the police the next day she goes to a
therapy session and finds out that Dr
Stern is her new psychiatrist Wendy
shares her encounter with Merrick but
tries to brush it off as a dream however
Dr CERN becomes suspicious and decides
to amp her dosage of her daily
medication later when Wendy returns home
she finds an eviction note on the door
further adding to her stress the
following evening she once again meets
Merrick outside the diner and has taken
aback all this while she had thought he
was merely Her Imagination but seeing
him face to face face after what
happened to the earlier night she cannot
believe her eyes Wendy tries to inquire
how he is still alive however Marek
simply hands her a flyer before fleeing
the scene because of the encounter Wendy
starts to feel overwhelmed so she
decides to stop taking her medication
the following day she experiences
withdrawal symptoms and finds it hard to
concentrate at work she becomes
increasingly irritable and
short-tempered on her way back Wendy is
confronted by a few cat callers which
triggers her temper even more she
insults them nastily prompting one of
the men to Lunge towards her however
Wendy gets angrier by the second and
ends up pinning the man on the floor as
the other goons attack her she amazingly
hurls them into the air several meters
away Wendy on the other hand doesn't
seem to be phased and returns home as if
nothing has happened turns out she has
regained her abilities which had been
suppressed by the medication the movie
then cuts to her co-worker Almar having
breakfast with his parents they always
encourage him to join University and
pursue a career in law but Omar refuses
it is revealed that he is fascinated
with superhero comics and has no
ambition for life one day at work Angela
finds a broken piece of kitchen
equipment and angrily has a go at Wendy
she even threatens to take it out of her
paycheck unable to contain her anger
Wendy loses it and lifts her boss by the
caller shouting at her to be polite
after she gets an apology she lets
Angela go but not before warning her to
watch out and take care in the future
elmar also Witnesses all of this from
nearby but instead of getting shocked he
seems impressed confused as to what is
happening to her body Wendy takes out
the flyer given to her by Merrick and
heads to the address written on it after
a while she ends up in an abandoned
water park where she finally meets
Merrick he explains that the new
symptoms Wendy is experiencing aren't
anything wrong but are instead her true
self he also reveals that they aren't
the only ones and that the government
has been prescribing medications to
those who have powers in order to
suppress them even Dr Stern is involved
in the conspiracy hearing this Wendy
becomes angry and decides to find the
true so she makes her way to Dr Stern's
office and breaks in as when he searches
through her files she stumbles upon the
shocking discovery that her colleague
elmar is also one of Dr Stern's patients
concerned about his well-being Wendy
decides to pay him a visit she Surprises
elmar by climbing through his window and
urges him to stop taking the blue pills
that suppress his powers she wants him
to embrace his abilities and become a
real man the following day Wendy's
Newfound confidence allows her to
confront Angela and finally secure the
promotion she has been eyeing for so
long later elmar approaches her and
reveals that he has stopped taking the
pills he also displays his new power the
ability to generate electricity the two
then decide to celebrate by taking a
walk and along the way Wendy uses her
abilities to rob an ATM machine they
eventually end up dancing and having fun
inside a club there Wendy spots some
guys bothering other women and acting
rash so to teach them a lesson she along
with Almar lure them into the bathroom
and beat them to a pulp after reaching
home Wendy surprises her husband with
the money needed to pay off their debts
meanwhile it's revealed that one of the
dudes who was beaten up inside the club
has reported the incident to the police
the officials don't believe that a
single woman could have taken on
multiple guys and so they assume that he
is crazy but just then Dr Stern shows up
at the station and explains to them that
the woman is indeed superhuman one day
Wendy takes Almar to the abandoned Water
Theme Park where they meet Merrick the
latter is wary at first but soon becomes
happy when Almar showcases his powers by
powering up the entire theme park
following this Merrick mentions a
facility where they keep and run tests
on people like them he explains that
from the outside it looks like a
psychiatric ward but deep within it is a
prison Merrick reveals that he too spent
many years inside this desolate prison
hearing this Wendy thinks of a plan to
rescue the prisoners inside of the
facility she and Almar also convince
Merrick to tag along later upon arriving
at the facility Wendy puts on a disguise
and flirts with the guard she ends up
tricking him and ties him up while elmar
uses his powers to show Short Circuit
the entire system disabling the cameras
as they make their way to the patient's
cells they are spotted by the guards who
manage to shoot Merrick however he is
totally unaffected due to his near
Invincible body as the trio runs outside
they are surrounded by a dozen guards
but elmar electrocutes them in an
instant before running away Wendy is
sickened by the violence she just
witnessed she is especially worried that
the guards might be dead but Almar seems
to be unaffected he instead boasts his
abilities and declares his desire to
become a superhero Merrick however is
furious with almar's words and explains
that his Reckless attitude is what led
to people like them being locked up in
the first place he reveals that he once
tried to be a hero which ultimately
resulted in the tragic deaths of his
wife and daughter later Wendy returns
home to find a drunk Lars waiting for
her he's upset that she didn't go to
work and immediately assumes that she's
been cheating on him Wendy is confused
and doesn't know what to say but the
next morning in an effort to salvage her
relationship with her husband she lies
and admits to having an there with a
colleague from work however she also
explains that she has ended it Lars
eventually decides to forgive her but
their relationship is strained meanwhile
elmar meets with Dr Stern and admits
that he has been experiencing strange
Visions lately he confesses that he
dreamed of a homeless person living in
an abandoned water park referring to
Merrick and betraying him the movie then
cuts to the water park where Merrick's
Hideout is raided by the police and he
is captured back at Wendy's house she is
having a backyard party with several
friends and acquaintances fed up with
the recent events she simply wants to
spend some time with her family however
things take a drastic turn when elmar
shows up uninvited and informs Wendy of
Merrick's arrest he tries to convince
her to run away with him and start a new
life but she rejects him and kicks him
out of the house meanwhile Lars becomes
Furious when he sees elmar leaving and
assumes that he is the man Wendy was
having an affair with he confronts her
about it leading to an argument Wendy
who is unable to continue with her lies
any longer finally reveals her abilities
but Lars isn't convinced he starts
believing the she is delusional this
makes Wendy so angry that she hurts Lars
through the coffee table while her son
stares at them in complete shock the
other guests also witnessed this and
realizing that she has been exposed
Wendy quickly flees the scene on the
other hand elmar is consumed by his
thirst for power and control he takes
out his frustration on his father and
electrocutes him making him fall to the
floor Wendy who happens to be nearby
hears the commotion and rushes to help
however by the time she reaches the old
man he is unresponsive elmar again tries
to convince Wendy to join forces but as
expected she refuses unfortunately the
decision turns out to be a costly one as
elmar angrily electrocutes her as well
rendering her unconscious when she comes
to her senses Wendy finds herself
strapped to a bed in a facility with Dr
Stern the latter informs her that elmar
is on the run while his father has
luckily been resuscitated by the
paramedics Wendy then tries to free
herself from the table while Dr Stern
tells her that it is for her own safety
and flashback shows a young Wendy with
her mother in the principal's office she
had been struggling to connect with her
classmates and as a result the principal
confiscated her CD player no all of a
sudden Wendy ascends into a fit of rage
and lift the table up with her bare
hands she then launches it with full
force towards the principal killing him
brutally punch that into your calculator
teach in the present Dr Stern reassures
Wendy that she isn't a freak but just
needs special care so Wendy is admitted
into the same psychiatric ward that she
previously broke into Dr Stern then
visits Lars and requests him to bring
Wendy's Son Carl into her office she
wants to make sure the little boy is not
inflicted with any special powers as
days pass by Wendy is forced to take
medication while inside the facility she
also meets Merrick there but it's clear
that he has accepted his Fate One Day
elmar visits Wendy and tells her that
they are meant to be together he also
promises to free her from the facility
however Wendy ignores all of his claims
and instead calls the guards for help
enraged at the Betrayal elmar announces
that he will go after her family and
kill them one one by one in the next
scene we get to know that Carl has also
been prescribed the blue pills from Dr
Stern all of a sudden the power is cut
off from their house and elmar arrives
there back at the facility there is a
similar power cut which enables the
prisoners to escape including Wendy
however once outside she is confronted
by Dr Stern and a few guards things look
Grim for our protagonist but out of
nowhere Merrick arrives at the scene and
saves Wendy he bravely fights the guards
and subdues them one by one
unfortunately in the process he is shot
multiple times as America's on
medication his powers are sedated and
thus he peacefully dies hoping to see
his family again a while later Wendy
makes it home where she finds her family
being held hostage by the crazy elmar
she tries punching him but without her
powers it is not of much use just then
Lars tosses her a rubber glove so that
she can hit elmar without getting
electrocuted the plan works and at the
same time Wendy's medication also wears
off and she regains her powers using all
her strength she then punches elmar
through the wall and into the poof I
mean in the pool where he electrocutes
himself and dies after the ordeal Wendy
tearfully Embraces her family knowing
that it's time for her to leave and
protect them from the government she
promises to keep in touch and departs
with a heartfelt goodbye as she walks
away Wendy feels a newfound sense of
purpose and determination to take down
the corrupt system that had imprisoned
her years later we see Wendy as a
vigilante using her powers to fight for
justice and protect those who can't
protect themselves she keeps a watchful
eye on her family from a distance always
making sure that they're safe and sound
but Wendy's mission is far from over as
she tracks down the ones who had escaped
the facility seeking to bring them to
justice and ensure that no one else has
to suffer like she did the post-credits
scene of the movie then reveals that
Carl has inherited his mother's genes as
he defends himself from his bullies by
making them float time to vote subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching